[Music]
hey everyone and welcome back to the
playstation competition center and our
coverage of tekken 7.
i'm mark van and i'm here with riff and
today we're going to talk to you about
the rage system
exactly rage is a mechanic that gives
you more power when you're closer to
being ko so let's quickly take a look at
that
in tekken 7 your health are split into
two colors about 80
one color and 20 another color when you
take enough damage and are at about 20
health you will hear a special sound
effect and the health bar's border
starts to flash red
your character is now enraged and all
your attacks will do increased damage
this is of course very useful in itself
especially if you have to make
a big comeback but there's more once you
have rage available
you get access to two entirely new moves
these are called
rage drives and rage arts the rage drive
is an entirely new move only accessible
while in rage
when one is performed the camera will
shift and the character will flash blue
each character's rage drive is unique
there are commonly very fast
flooding attacks that will lead to more
offense even if they're blocked
and if they hit they will lead to
massive damage they may even be used in
the middle of a combo to earn more
damage than what is normally possible
rage drives are very strong tools that
must be respected and will often make
the defender nervous when they're
opponents near ko
rage arts on the other hand are
cinematic super attacks that do a lot of
raw damage
importantly they have armor at the
beginning of the move which means you
can blow through an opponent's attack
however you still take damage from any
hit you armor through and this can ko
you
so they are less useful when you are
extremely low on health however
the lower your health bar the more
damage your weight charge will do
unlike rage drives if your opponent
anticipates your rage arc
most are easily blocked or avoided and
your opponent can punish you with a
counter attack so they are more often
used as a high damage
desperation move or as a combo finisher
once you use your rage driver rage art
you no longer have access to the passive
damage boost
and you can no longer do another rage
art or rage drive for the rest of the
round
so if you have to make a comeback you
have to make sure it counts otherwise
you lose the extra damage
it's important to make sure that you're
able to use it towards the end of the
round to make sure you actually
hail your opponent right and rage drives
and rage yards are very powerful tools
that you really don't want to forget
about when you're beginner player
and of course you know they're such a
big comeback mechanic that you really
have to kind of experiment with your
character to see which ones work best
for you
that's it for this episode this tutorial
was made in partnership with the
playstation competition center team
you can check out more at
compete.playstation.com
to watch learn and to compete subscribe
to the bne esports channel for more
tutorials
and tekken 7 content